so time then for the press preview and
first look at what is on the front pages
for bank holiday monday and tonight
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the deputy online editor at the new
statesman rachel cunliffe
and westminster correspondent at the
yorkshire post jerry scott a very happy
easter to both of you nice to see you
we'll chat in a moment first of all
though let's take a look at some of
those front pages
starting with the eye leading with
government plans to give everyone in
england access to two rapid covered
tests a week from friday
even if they show no symptoms the daily
telegraph also
splashes with the same story saying the
multi-billion pound scheme will be paid
for by the government
and could pave the way for workplaces to
request negative
tests the yorkshire post leads also with
the new rapid covered tests that will
give results in half an hour and will be
available
to everyone to do at home the daily mail
takes the angle that despite the
expanding testing and vaccinations there
are concerns the easing of lockdown
may lead to a worrying uptick in
coronavirus cases
here's your guardian saying the increase
in testing comes as the government faces
growing opposition to the idea of
app-based
passports to let people into crowded
places and events
and let's slide in the ft writing that
china's central bank has
asked lenders to reigning credit supply
with concerns the huge lending that
helped it swift
coronavirus recovery could cause
financial trouble
and we're joined bye rachel conniff and
jerry scott great to see you both
so let's start then with uh what is
pretty much on every front page the
news this evening that free weekly covid
tests are going to be offered to
everyone
in england uh rachel this is uh well it
could be a game changer couldn't it
a kid i remember when when matt hancock
raised the possibility
months ago of uh on unlimited testing to
help keep track of outbreaks as they
emerged
he called it operation moonshot and the
government wasn't doing too well at the
moment
a lot of people made jokes about that
you know shooting for the moon the idea
that it would actually happen
um be very unlikely it looks like it is
set to happen
costing 1.3 billion the government has
ordered millions of lateral flow
tests and the announcements tomorrow
which by the way is
a year since the prime minister went
into hospital himself with with covert
19 and had that very worrying
experience there over he's going to
announce tomorrow that
uh everyone in the in england will be
encouraged
to take two of these tests a week
they'll be provided free
and that will be a way for them to make
sure even if they're not vaccinated
that they are safe and not risking
transmission
um which is positive in one way because
it means
that uh that there won't be
discrimination between people who have
been offered the vaccination
and people who haven't been offered it
yet you know being barred from pubs we
heard a lot about that the idea that
young people could be
barred from pubs just because they
haven't been offered the vaccine yet
it is still a huge logistical challenge
that comes with its own
issues uh but it is it is a sort of
monumental
um scheme that the government is
introducing at this point that
will probably allay some people's fears
that we're easing lockdown without
enough of a plan
for how to limit the risks uh yeah jerry
it's the same story on the front of the
daily mail
two coveted tests each week for everyone
i suppose one of the issues here is will
everyone
use it and take it because uh one
problem is
you know if you're if you're a
freelancer or you're working the gig
economy
uh if you're a taxi driver or whatever
you may not want to take a test because
if it's
negative you can't work and if you can't
work you can't
earn money absolutely you know that's
one of the arguments that labour's put
across that actually what is still
missing here is the proper support in
place for those people that do get
those positive tests and not just that
reason either in your clip uh that we
saw just before we
came on we saw some people doing those
tests and they're not the most
comfortable i don't think everyone is
quite on board quite yet
we're taking them but you know there are
lots of uh different ways you can get
them in this announcement tomorrow it
says you're going to be able to pick up
kind of seven at a time from a pharmacy
to take home and to keep at home
that you know you can have them at the
hubs that we already know about so it
sounds like they're going to be really
easily accessible and delivered to your
home
as well so it's going to be as easy as
possible for people to take these tests
and i think the message that we're going
to get tomorrow and in the coming weeks
hammering at home is how important
this is and this is the way that we can
get our lives back to normal i really
think that's the message that the prime
minister is going to
try and get across from by the way the
brand new press briefing room tomorrow
which will be very exciting to see
yes rachel uh tomorrow the prime
minister will uh give us
a lot more detail the front of the daily
telegraph
talks about a potential defeat though
for the prime minister when it comes to
a vote on vaccine passports or covid
status
certification as we should be calling it
i mean more than 70 mps we're hearing
including more than 40
tories uh signing this open letter to
the prime minister opposing the use of
vaccine passports i mean what's going to
happen there do you think
so this is fascinating and if i have if
i have my cynical politics
hat on i would suggest that this is
actually one of the driving forces
behind the announcement of of mass
testing because it takes the focus away
from
quote vaccine passports and towards
wider certification testing vaccine
integrated measures which would monitor
the water somewhat and the prime
minister gets to say this isn't about
vaccine passports this is about
testing and and reducing risk um because
he knows that there are significant
number of his own
mps who are very very hostile to the
idea of vaccine passports
and and rightly so if you if you look at
the
implications of a surveillance state a
government
that has a way to track citizens it's
about
vaccination status now but it is a form
of
id and the blab government obviously had
many many issues with the
bringing in some form of national id
cards what i think is interesting is
there is this coalition between
um the the right-wing tory wing uh the
tory mps people like david davis who
have called this nonsense
to gray and brady has has come out
against it but you've also got the
liberal democrats on
on the left saying hang on let's think
about the civil rights implications
do you think rachel sorry to jump in
because i want to get jerry's thoughts i
want to get jerry's thoughts on it but
but do you think that actually when it
comes to it we know that the majority of
the public the latest polls suggesting
will be willing to show proof of a
negative test you know you have all the
arguments about civil liberties and
surveillance society and all the rest of
it but at the end of the day
most people simply want to go and have a
drink or go to the theater or go and
watch the footy
and if it means showing a passport or a
covered passport flashing something on
your phone then they're prepared to do
it
uh they of course everyone's scared at
the moment and the last thing anyone
wants to
do now is to see transmission rates
increase and i'm sure
people would support measures that would
reduce that
in the short term the issue is
governments that seize power
very rarely want to give that power back
and i think it's the job of mps not just
to look at the situation now
but to look at how that power could be
abused in the future and to make sure if
we do
implement something like this there are
limits on it and to make sure this is
not a long term thing after covert has
passed
yeah and certainly jerry the government
seemed to be uh uh
are very aware of that at the moment
there's no sign of pubs
uh or restaurants for example requiring
uh
certificates uh and also um a lot of
talk about them putting a definite end
date onto it
yeah absolutely i think that's going to
be really important for these you know
touring especially who are thinking of
rebelling because this isn't a new
argument we've had it with
you know the extending of the lockdown
regulations that
really a lot of these mps don't feel
like this is a government anymore that
you know stands for
small state this is a big state
intervention it's really worrying and
it's kind of
getting to the straw that broke the
camel's back now so
i really think that putting end dates on
it's going to be absolutely crucial and
we know that michael gove has already
been kind of dispatched to try and
calm things down a bit whether that will
have helped matters or not we'll uh
we'll see when it goes to a vote that's
been promised i suppose um
let's go and have a look at your paper
jerry just staying with you the
yorkshire post uh
away from uh coronavirus i mean you are
talking about the fast test twice a week
of course on on the front page there but
you've also got this story which is
really
uplifting isn't it quicker and kinder
cancer job for breast cancer past
for nhs use tell us about this
yeah absolutely and i'm going to
pronounce it wrong i absolutely know i
am but it's a lovely story and it's um
basically all about this cancer job it's
cutting the time that breast cancer
patients have to be in hospital from two
and a half hours to just
five minutes which is a massive change
and especially in this time you know
this pandemic time where
we know that people who are vulnerable
are you know really at risk from
coronavirus cutting the amount of time
they have to have in hospital
absolutely makes this is a significant
cut to their code of 19 risk and
it's only for 15 of breast cancer
patients who have
a particular type of breast cancer but
it does mean that they can get
kind of two jabs in one um while they're
having their chemotherapy and
one of the first patients to have it uh
paula lam said it's going to give her
more time to go on walks which is um
something we've obviously all been
enjoying during coronavirus but will be
much better way to spend your time than
sitting in a hospital i'm absolutely
sure so that's been licensed
on the nhs it's called fezgo i'm going
to pronounced it wrong but it's a
massive game changer it's really
brilliant and of course rachel the other
thing this does
uh is free up staff in a hospital to do
other urgent work and with the
the huge backlog that we're uh
experiencing now and the huge pressure
of the nhs is under then that's that's
also a good thing
that's exactly right and i'm so pleased
to jerry for pronouncing it so i didn't
have to
um but this story is is sort of being
sold as it's great because it reduces
covert risk for cancer patients which is
great and it is important
but the the wider um implications are
it frees up uh health capacity for other
health care workers and limits the
amount of time they have to spend in
hospital
which is obviously hugely traumatic in
itself not just in a pandemic
spending lots of time in in hospital
when you have a chronic condition
uh eats away at a mental health and it
will help
on that front so one of the things that
i'm really feeling positive
about with this story is the idea that
because of covid
a huge amount of innovations will have
occurred in healthcare
not just this particular job but in in
the way hospitals operate
in new treatments in in new ways of
seeing patients
integrated with technology that they've
had to adapt because of the pandemic but
some of those improvements will continue
afterwards and that will be really
positive for patients in the future yeah
great to finish
part one of the papers uh on a positive
note uh for now
thank you both very much indeed coming
up after the break female teachers
as well as people suffer a culture of
sexual abuse within schools that's
according to
a teaching union leader talking about
that and more
in a couple of minutes hello again part
two of the press preview still with me
deputy online editor at the new
statesman rachel conley from westminster
correspondent at the york's post jerry
scott um let's have a look at front of
the guardian
uh jerry and uh this story which um
we've been reporting for the last couple
of weeks but it's taken another
uh twist teachers also suffering a
culture of
toxic abuse talk us through this
yeah absolutely and this is you're quite
right something that's been kind of
hanging around the last couple of weeks
isn't it in there
the kind of you know sexual assault
allegations that we're hearing in in
lots of schools but we've now got unions
saying that actually this harassment um
by boys is actually the tip of the
iceberg and that female teachers
are being targeted as well and the
accusation here is
that you know if schools are tolerating
this kind of behavior
between pupils that actually it's
happening to
all kind of female people in in the
school
and uh the warning here is that they're
um really scared to walk corridors alone
in some schools and are facing abuse and
harassment
and it's it's really worrying actually
and you know this has all been ignited
it's a massive
obviously national conversation at the
moment about how safe women and girls
feel
at work out on the streets at home as
well
and it's just another kind of you know
um
i guess incident where we're shown that
women
don't feel safe in lots of areas of
their life and
um yeah it's a really really worrying
story yeah rachel we've heard some uh
desperate testimony haven't we um in in
recent weeks from uh from women and and
very young girls
yes and i think the school point is a
really important part of that
conversation i know when
uh we first started talking about this
with with sarah everest killing
uh one of the the questions was what
could we do to make
women and girls feel safe and what can
we do to communicate that the minority
of men who do this
uh need to be held accountable and need
to be taught that that is not acceptable
and that conversation starts off at
school school is an environment
where uh there is a it should be
a certain amount of oversight and
accountability where you can really keep
an eye on
young people as they are growing up and
when you spot problematic behaviors
you can address them in a in a safe and
secure environment that's what's meant
to happen
if what you have instead is a a toxic
culture where people behave in a certain
way and there are no consequences
that is going to be a lesson that
unfortunately some of them take on into
their adult lives
because they have uh acted in a certain
way with impunity
and so tackling that in schools is a
really important part of the
conversation
yeah of course okay and let's finish
with this story on the front of the
daily telegraph
bank holiday monday tomorrow hopefully
not too many people having to work but
we're hearing that civil servants
may be offered the chance to go to work
in hybrid offices
in future jerry yeah absolutely and
actually this
really builds on something that we do a
lot of reporting on at the yorkshire
place which is uh moving civil servants
out of london and you're right the story
is that
civil servants will be able to work from
uh it's up to ten i think city bases to
begin with these are kind of
co-co-working flexible working hubs in
um this deal
with uh iwg and it's ten cities and also
all their
other sites so that's a kind of massive
you know change from
if you think you know before the
pandemic and we'd all cram into
you know onto the bus or the train or
the tube or into our cars and commute
and
it's going to really i think
revolutionize the way that the civil
service works and hopefully also give
opportunities for really good talent to
go into the civil service from areas
that aren't
london and the southeast we've had some
announcements recently about jobs moving
to leeds and to york
as well and obviously my neck of the
woods and my patch but we've heard of
others as well it's a really welcome
move to kind of diversify the civil
service which can
actually only be good for government and
policy making in my opinion
so it's a really really good move but
also i think shows the changing nature
of work post-pandemic
yeah well i was going to say that rachel
i mean the pandemic has really changed
so many things about our working lives
hasn't it from uh
over over zoom that we've all got very
used to to actually working from home
and it's going to change how our city
centers look
you tell me that work has changed i
started a new job in january i haven't
met any of my colleagues yet
i have been communicating with them
purely over a screen
for the past three months so i'm very
much looking forward to any kind of
office contact at all
just to be able to say hello to them in
person but in terms of this particular
story i think this is
the clearest sign yet that stuff is not
going back to normal in exactly the same
way
as it was pre-covered because a civil
service is a huge organization
so many people employed and those
working patterns within those
organizations are going to set trends
for other businesses and other employers
so i think some kind of return to
an office environment at least part-time
is is definitely going to happen
but we're getting a sense here that it's
going to be flexible it's going to be
hybrid it's going to be more locations
with um
with with more options more more hot
desking it's not going to be the
standard
nine to five and therefore you you you
buy a home where you rent a home very
very close to someone that you know you
could have
the same commute into for the next ten
years okay rachel i'm sorry to interrupt
we're gonna have to leave it there we're
out of time but enjoy the rest of uh
the bank holiday weekend don't don't
work too hard thank you both very much